كانتا تغنيان
يهذا النص تغيان
وروي عن النبي محمد
فقال لعائشة تعرفين من هذه قال لا
هذه مغنية قبيلة .. فنانة .. مطربه ..في عقدنا هذا
تحبين ان تغني .. فقالت نعم فا اعطها طبقاً وغنته
وجاء النبي الى عرس وهناك مراه تغني وتضرب في الدف وتغني وتقول
وفينا نبي يعلم ما في غداً
من إمام للحرم المكي إلى ممثل في هوليوود!
شيء لا يصدق!
السعودية وعلماؤها إلى أين المسير؟
هل أصبحت أرض الحرمين الشريفين
أرضا للهو واللعب،...
والخمر والقمار والفسوق والفجور؟
أين ذهب علماء المملكة
الذين صدحت أصواتهم في الآفاق؟
هل كانوا علماء للدين أم للدنيا؟
علماء السلطة والبلاط الملكي، أم دعاة ربانيون؟
ما هذا التناقض العجيب؟ صورة قديمة للكلباني
يؤم المصلين في الكعبة المشرفة، وأخرى وقد صار ممثلا
وواجهة دعائية لجماعة الترفيه؟
وهل يجيد الكلباني الغناء والرقص؟
(الكلباني بين الدعوة والترفيه،،
فما الذي يجري لعلماء السعودية؟)
(من هو الكلباني؟)
اسمه الشيخ عادل بن سالم بن سعيد الكلباني،،
هو إمام جامع المحيسن بحي أشبيلية في شمال شرق الرياض،
وكُلِّف بإمامة المصلين في صلاة التراويح
من عام 1429هـ من شهر رمضان بالمسجد الحرام بمكة المكرمة
أعفي من إمامة الحرم المكي بعد انتهاء تكليفه لإمامة المصلين
خلال شهر رمضان..
الكلباني هو داعية سعودي مثير للجدل،،
بتحوله المثير من رجل الدين ذي الآراء والمواقف الجريئة،
إلى رجل الدين المقرب من بلاط الملوك والسلاطين،
ذاع صيته بعد أن نشط في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وبعد ظهوره في القنوات الفضائية بمواقفه الجريئة،
ولجرأته الشديدة حينها لُقب في السعودية
بقاصف الجبهات!! وكان أبرز مواقفه هو كلامه عن ضعف الدين
في هذا الزمن وعلاقة الحكام بالدين واستغلاهم له عند الاحتياج فقط،،،
(وإلى هنا لا زلت على الطريق السليم وعلى مبدئك يا كلباني)..
الكلباني خرج مجددا وبرأ الإخوان المسلمين من الفكر الداعشي،
بعكس ما يقوله أمراء وملوك السعودية،
(اللهم قوِ إيمانه).
وقال إن الفكر الذي تحمله داعش هو فكر سلفي وهابي،
أي أنه أقرب للفكر السعودي وليس فكر الإخوان أو سيد قطب.
وسبق أن انتقد الكلباني أول معرض (كوميك كون) على الإطلاق في المملكة،
عام 2017، وقال حينها على تويتر
إن الهيئة التي أنشئت لتعزيز مساعي المملكة للترفيه
"تخالف الجبلة. أي ما جبل عليه الإنسان وهو اللجوء إلى الله في المحن والفتن".
الكلباني يرفع من حدة جرأته بانتقاده تصنيف حركة المقاومة الإسلامية
حماس كحركة إرهابية في العام ٢٠١٧ في تغريدة له على تويتر،
فجعل ذلك منه هدفا للذباب الإلكتروني متهمينه بذي الميول الإخوانية،
ما دفع الكلباني للاختفاء عن عالم التواصل،،
وبعد غيابه لفترة عاد الكلباني ويااااليته لم يعد!!
فهذا الكلباني الذي صدم  رجال الدين المحافظين في العام ٢٠١٠،
بتأييده للغناء، قائلا إنه لا يوجد ما يحرمه لا في القرآن ولا في الأحاديث النبوية.
وبعد شهر أعلن أنه سحب اعتراضه.
ثم أفتى مؤخرا على تويتر،،
وقال إن الموسيقى والمعازف "مباحة" تماما.
على الرغم أنه ليس بمفتٍ ليثير الجدل مجددا...
فهو من كبار رجال الدين لكنه ليس عضوا في هيئة كبار العلماء المعينة من الدولة،
وهي الهيئة الوحيدة في المملكة التي يجوز لها إصدار الفتاوى الرسمية.،،
(تغيير جذري)..
...
كل المواقف السابقة جعلت من الكلباني شخصية مثيرة للجدل،
لكن يبدو أنه قرر ألا يكون كذلك مرة أخرى،
وانتقل للطرف المعاكس تماما،
فأصبحت فتاواه في صالح هيئة الترفيه
التي جاءت بديلة عن هيئة الأمر بالمعروف والنهي عن المنكر،،
هذه الهيئة التي أدخلت الراقصات والمغنيات الخليعات
إلى أرض الحرمين ونشرت العهر والفجور،
بل أن الكلباني أفتى بإزالة الساتر والحواجز بين الرجال والنساء
في الجامعات والمدارس بل وحتى في الجوامع والمساجد أثناء الصلاة،
مستدلا بما كان يحدث في عهد النبي(ص)،،
(لكن ما هكذا تورد الإبل يا كلباني)،
(أو كل هذا من أجل الترفيه أيها الشيخ المبجل؟)،،
فلو اكتفى الكلباني بلحيته فقط ما ولج في هذا الإناء!
فما بالنا بمن كان يوما إماما للحرم المكي؟
(يا لتعاستك يا كلباني!!!)،،،، لم يكتف الكلباني بهذا!!
بل أباح الرقص وزعم أن النبي(ص)
كان يستضيف الراقصات في منزله،،
وقال إن المرأة مطالب بفعل ما يتقنه فإن أتقنت الرقص فارقص!!!
الكلباني اعترف أيضا بتطبيله للحكام!!!
لكن كل ذلك في كفة وأن يصبح الكلباني ممثلا ووجه دعائيا لهيئة الترفيه
وأن يقوم بأنشطة صبيانية فهذا هو الجنون بذاته،
فبدلا أن يختم الكلباني عمره في زوايا المساجد،
ها هو يظهر كلاعب بالوت، وكومبارس في لعبة بلايستيشن،
ويتساءل إن كان باستطاعته أن يكون يوما ما ممثلا في هوليوود!!
(أ بعد هذا العمر كله؟ في الدعوة وإمامة المصلين
ترغب في دخول السينما يا كلباني؟؟
لعمري لهذا العجب العجاب!!!!)
....
هل يعتبر الكلباني وغيره من علماء البلاط الملكي
منفرين عن الدين الإسلامي؟
بعد أن كانت المملكة أرضا لعلماء الدين التقاة والدعاة إلى دين الله
هل صارت اليوم أرضا لأمثال الكلباني ؟؟